Il se trouve que nous combattons l'un des processus d'apprentissage
les plus conservés au cours de l'évolution de la science,
qui a été conservé
dans le système nerveux le plus basique connu.
Cet apprentissage basé sur la récompense
est appelé renforcement positif et négatif
et fonctionne de la façon suivante :
nous voyons de la nourriture qui paraît bonne,
notre cerveau nous dit : « Des calories ! ...Survie ! »
Nous mangeons cette nourriture
et ça a bon goût.
Et, surtout avec le sucre,
le corps envoie un signal au cerveau qui dit :
« Rappelle-toi ce que tu manges et où tu l'as trouvé. »
Nous imposons cette mémoire dépendant du contexte
et apprenons à répéter le processus la fois suivante.
Je vois de la nourriture,
je mange, je me sens bien,
je recommence.
Déclencheur, comportement, récompense.
Simple, n'est-ce pas ?
Eh bien, avec le temps, notre cerveau créatif dit :
« Tu sais quoi ?
Tu peux t'en servir pour autre chose que juste te rappeler où est la nourriture.
La prochaine fois que tu te sens mal,
pourquoi ne pas essayer de manger pour te sentir mieux ? »
Nous remercions notre cerveau pour l'idée,
nous essayons et apprenons vite
que si nous mangeons du chocolat ou de la glace quand nous sommes tristes,
nous nous sentons mieux.
Même processus,
mais avec un déclencheur différent.
Au lieu du signal de faim venant de notre estomac,
le signal émotionnel, se sentir triste,
déclenche l'envie de manger.
Peut-être qu'à l'adolescence
nous étions un geek à l'école,
et en voyant les rebelles fumer dehors, nous pensions :
« Je veux être cool moi aussi. »
Alors nous commençons à fumer.
Le Marlboro Man n'était pas un ringard et ce n'était pas accidentel.
Je vois des gens cools,
je fume pour être cool,
je me sens bien, je recommence.
Déclencheur, comportement, récompense.
Chaque fois que nous faisons ça,
nous apprenons à répéter le processus
et ça devient une habitude.
Ainsi, plus tard,
se sentir stressé déclenche cette envie de fumer une cigarette
ou de manger quelque chose.
A présent, avec ces mêmes processus cérébraux,
nous sommes passés d'apprendre à survivre,
jusqu'à littéralement nous tuer avec nos habitudes.
L'obésité et le tabagisme
font partie des premières causes évitables de morbidité et de mortalité au monde.
Revenons à ma respiration.
Imaginez qu'au lieu de lutter contre notre cerveau,
ou d'essayer de nous forcer à être attentif,
nous profitions de cet apprentissage naturel basé sur la récompense...
mais avec une variante ?
Imaginez que l'on devienne vraiment curieux
à propos de ce qu'il se passe dans le moment présent ?
Je vous donne un exemple.
Dans mon labo, nous avons tenté de savoir
si la pleine conscience pouvait aider à arrêter de fumer.
Tout comme me forcer à prêter attention à ma respiration,
ils esssayaient de se forcer à arrêter de fumer.
La majorité d'entre eux avait essayé cela et avait échoué
en moyenne six fois.
Avec la pleine conscience,
nous nous sommes concentrés sur le fait d'être curieux.
En fait, nous leur avons même dit de fumer.
Oui, nous leur avons dit : « Allez-y, fumez,
soyez juste curieux à propos de ce que ça fait quand vous le faites. »
Et qu'est-ce qu'ils ont remarqué ?
Eh bien voici un exemple venant de l'un de nos fumeurs.
Elle a dit : « Fumer en pleine conscience,
ça sent le fromage qui pue
et ça a un goût de produits chimiques,
BEURK ! »
Elle savait bien, intellectuellement, que fumer était mauvais pour elle,
c'est pour ça qu'elle a rejoint notre programme.
Elle a alors découvert, en fumant de façon consciente et curieuse,
que fumer a un goût de merde.
(Rires)
Elle est alors passée du savoir à la sagesse.
Elle est passée de savoir que fumer était mauvais pour elle
jusqu'à le sentir physiquement
et le sortilège de la cigarette a été rompu.
Elle a commencé à être désenchantée par son comportement.
Le cortex préfrontal,
la partie la plus jeune du cerveau du point de vue de l'évolution,
comprend sur le plan intellectuel que nous ne devrions pas fumer
et il fait tout son possible pour nous aider à changer notre comportement,
pour nous aider à arrêter,
pour nous empêcher de manger ce deuxième, ce troisième, ce quatrième gâteau.
On appele ça contrôle cognitif.
Nous utilisons la cognition pour contrôler notre comportement.
Malheureusement,
c'est aussi la première partie de notre cerveau
à se déconnecter quand nous stressons,
ce qui n'aide pas.
Nous avons tous déjà vécu ce type d'expérience.
Nous sommes plus susceptibles de crier sur nos proches
quand nous sommes stressés ou fatigués,
même si nous savons que ça ne nous aidera pas.
C'est plus fort que nous.
Quand le cortex préfrontal se déconnecte,
nous retombons dans nos travers,
ce qui explique pourquoi le désenchantement est si important.
Voir le résultat de nos habitudes
nous aide à les comprendre plus profondément,
à le savoir physiquement
pour que nous n'ayons pas à nous retenir
ou réprimer notre comportement.
Nous sommes juste moins intéressés par le faire à la base.
C'est là tout le principe de la pleine conscience :
voir très clairement le résultat de nos mauvaises habitudes,
devenir désenchanté à un niveau viscéral
et, à partir de cette position désenchantée, lâcher prise.
Je ne dis pas que l'on puisse arrêter de fumer comme par magie,
mais avec le temps, alors que nous apprenons à mieux voir
le résultat de nos actions,
nous abandonnons nos vieilles habitudes et en créons de nouvelles.
Le paradoxe ici
est que la pleine conscience consiste juste à vouloir
se familiariser avec
ce qui se passe dans notre corps et notre esprit
d'un moment à l'autre.
La volonté de nous tourner vers notre expérience
plutôt que d'essayer de faire partir des pulsions aussi vite que possible.
Et notre volonté de nous tourner vers notre expérience
est appuyée par la curiosité,
ce qui est naturellement gratifiant.
Quel effet ça fait, la curiosité ?
Ça fait du bien.
Et que se passe-t-il quand nous devenons curieux ?
Nous remarquons que nos pulsions sont simplement faites de sensations.
Oh, il y a de la contraction, de la tension,
de la nervosité,
et que ces sensations vont et viennent.
Ce sont des petits morceaux d'expériences
que nous gérons d'un moment à l'autre
plutôt que d'être écrasé par cette énorme pulsion
qui nous étouffe.
En d'autres termes, quand nous devenons curieux,
nous sortons de nos vieilles habitudes réactives basées sur la peur
et nous apprenons à vivre dans le présent.
Nous devenons ce scientifique intérieur
qui attend avec impatience la prochaine donnée.
Cela peut sembler trop simpliste pour changer un comportement,
mais dans une étude, nous avons découvert que la pleine conscience
était 2 fois plus bénéfique
que les meilleures thérapies pour arrêter de fumer.
Cela marche donc vraiment.
Et quand nous avons étudié les cerveaux de méditants expérimentés,
nous avons découvert que des parties du réseau neuronal
du processus d'auto-référence,
appelé réseau du mode par défaut,
étaient en jeu.
Une hypothèse courante est qu'une région de ce réseau,
appelée le cortex cingulaire postérieur,
n'est pas activée par la pulsion elle-même,
mais quand nous sommes piégés par elle
et qu'elle nous emmène en balade.
A l'inverse, quand nous lâchons prise,
sortons du processus
en étant juste curieusement conscient de ce qu'il se passe,
cette même région du cerveau se calme.
Actuellement, nous testons des programmes d'entraînement de pleine conscience
qui visent ces mécanismes centraux
et, ironiquement, utilisent la même technologie qui nous distrait
pour nous aider à sortir de nos habitudes malsaines
de fumer, de manger pour évacuer le stress et ainsi de suite.
Vous souvenez-vous de la mémoire dépendant du contexte ?
Nous pouvons fournir ces outils à la portée des gens
dans les contextes les plus importants.
Ainsi nous pouvons les aider
à profiter de cette capacité innée à être curieusement conscient
juste quand cette envie de fumer, de manger par stress ou autre survient.
Donc si vous ne fumez pas ou ne mangez pas par stress,
peut-être qu'à la prochaine envie compulsive de vérifier vos e-mails,
ou que vous essayez d'échapper au travail,
ou peut-être de répondre compulsivement à un message pendant que vous conduisez,
essayez de profiter de cette capacité naturelle,
soyez curieusement conscient
de ce qu'il se passe dans votre corps et esprit à ce moment.
Ce sera une chance de plus
de perpétuer un de nos cercles vicieux...
ou d'en sortir.
Au lieu de voir un texto, répondre par reflexe et
se sentir mieux,
remarquez la pulsion,
devenez curieux,
soyez content de lâcher prise
et recommencez.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)